وفي تعليقه على التطورات عرب المبعوث
الاممي الخاص الى سوريا جير بدرسن عن قلقه
البالغ اذا تصعد العنفي في شمال سوريا
وحذر من ان تصاعد القتال قد يعرض
الاستقرار الاقليمي للخطر
مجلس الامن من السيناري الذي تكون فيه
للعمليات العسكريه
اثار غير مباشره في جميع المناطق الاخرى
مما يؤدي الى انهاء الهدوء النسبي الذي
دام ما يقرب من ثلاثه اعوام لن يؤديها مثل
هذا التصعيد الى تفاقم الضرر المدمر الذي
لاحق بالمدنيين السوريين فحسب بل سيعرض
ايضا الاستقرار الاقليميه للخطر الجماعه
الارهابيه التي تم اخذاها ولكن لم تهزم
ستستغل حاله عدم الاستقرار
الامريكيه في مجلس الامن الدولي لندن
ازاء الاعمال العسكريه الاخيره وتاثيرها
على استقرار المنطقه
ارقام فرصه ثانيه
على جميع الاطراف الموافقه على تنفيذ وقف
اطلاق نار شامل على مستوى البلاد يحمي
المدنيين من العنف تحث الولايات المتحده
على وقف فوري للتصعيد في شمال سوريا نحن
قلقون للغايه من الاعمال العسكريه الاخيره
التي تزعزع استقرار المنطقه وتهدد هدفنا
المشترك لمحاربه داعش وتعرض المدنيين
والافراد الامريكيين للخطر